scoring is like one of those records
like right now
if you go to the club no matter what
peak hour you're hearing that record
yeah and i like i feel like
get right with it was like a very la
record
and it was huge here but like scoring
feels
like it's like it's like a moment you
know what i'm saying like man
and it's a record and by the way it's a
record that y'all really like
worked because it came it's been out for
a minute bro yeah
it's been out for a hot ass minute
pandemic baby and and it's like
big bigger than you know like right now
it's probably the biggest it's been you
know what i mean
not for real i mean it's like it never
uh
i would i would say i'm blessed i'm not
gonna win it's never going backwards
like nothing that i've been doing since
i started doing stuff is going backwards
i still man you know so i'm just you
know i'm extremely appreciative that
it's it's
always a forward step no matter if it's
a slow step or you feel me no matter if
i'm standing still i'm not gonna act
like i ain't never been like paused
right i've definitely been at like some
standstills but i've never like
put a song out and then my next song did
horrible
you know and even when it like when it
has i knew why like because i didn't
drop [ __ ] like
winning against the win against the
label like i'm just trying to throw this
out and they're like bro you're
tripping like why did you do that but i
was being thirsty i wanted to have music
i thought i knew everything you right
so it's like everything is a learning
experience to me so like i never go into
the world thinking i know nothing i
always go in there willing to learn
mm-hmm so like it don't matter like
what's going on i'll never look and make
it seem like i
got the most information because you
feel me
knowledge makes you more powerful you
know it makes you the most powerful and
the most like you feel me you're wit and
all of that [ __ ]
and it's just like a [ __ ] could know so
much if you just shut the [ __ ] up and
listen to everything
everybody else is saying that's some
real [ __ ] like oh god you just gotta
shut the [ __ ] up sometimes
like really hey that's some real [ __ ]